[Music]
yes
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
uh
non-lethal you lose
exploding compression bullets
no one likes to show off unless they're
showing off as dope as
that's true
he does throw polka dots at me
sorry it's so
flamboyant it looks cool
i think
i don't like to kill people but if i
pretend they're my mom it's easy tmi
mate
[Music]
robert dubois
is in prison for putting superman in the
icu with the kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining your suicide squad
we'll see
[Music]
my court date is coming up and miss
wallace and maybe you can help me out
you're threatening my door out everyone
stand down
stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in
or out
good
let's meet your team
it's okay i'm not okay each member has
chosen for his or her own completely
unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf y'all next time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless i mean
he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
your mission
is to destroy every trace of something
known only as project starfish any
questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no
no
all right
let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
[Music]
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
now now it stay off the calm
[Music]
you